after pulling out of the Paris climate
Accord there was this rumor that Donald
Trump wasn't going to be invited to the
climate change summit in France and it
kind of made perfect sense as I said at
the time why would you invite Donald
Trump he is a distraction
he'll show up and insult people he'll
try to assert his dominance by pushing
other world leaders out of the way he'll
add nothing to the conversation he
thinks climate changes a hoax conjured
up by the Chinese why would you invite
Donald Trump even if he is the American
president to a summit where you were
going to have actual adults discussing
how to move forward productively and
mitigate pollution and mitigate global
warming and sea level rise and all of
the other negative repercussions of
climate change and defenders of Trump
said no no no no
Trump's going to be invited he won't go
because he's too good for it or he's too
smart or he's too busy or whatever
well the invites have gone out and the
event is in the more advanced planning
stages and President Donald Trump is not
invited 50 world leaders are going to be
meeting in Paris for a climate change
summit and Trump is simply not on the
list of invitees expect to tweet any day
now low-energy fake news Cissy French
president called and begged me to go and
when I told him no he says I'm not
invited to begin with we are busy with
the top stock market making America
great again no time for this bad or sick
guy would that fit into 280 characters
now maybe it was a little long this is
actually for me less about climate
change and more about the reputation of
the US around the world even if you
think climate changes a hoax and for
whatever reason more people in the u.s.
think that it's a hoax than in many
other countries around the world how can
the American exceptionalism types be
okay with the u.s. not having a seat at
the table an important table among 50
other countries on something with just
with such a major impact a climate
change which impacts a big portion of
the economy if I were one of the
southern conservatives or the rural
conservatives that voted for Donald
Trump for economic reasons I'd be
furious about this fighting climate
change
we'll actually be a job creating
explosion wind turbines have to be
manufactured somewhere solar panels have
to be installed somewhere they have to
be financed by someone that is all
economic opportunity that Trump is
taking himself and the u.s. out of the
running for I would be furious if I was
one of those vote for Trump for economic
reasons Trump yes I think those American
Exceptionalist tend to also be
nationalists too and want to pull away
from the rest of the world so I can see
them justifying that yes but if the
United States is going to prosper
economically you want to be selling
stuff to other countries don't you like
solar panels or wind turbine then you
have to convince those people that solar
panels and wind turbines are profitable
and a lot of them don't think that they
are they want a crowbar coal back into
the national and international
discussions and so yeah Pat's probably
right there are Trump is who will call
this a victory but it's definitely a
loss it's a major loss and Trump is no
longer going to let the French president
go to mera Lago so there he's gonna now
be punished because he didn't invite
Trump seriously though the fight against
climate change is going to need to go
around the United States as opposed to
being pushed forward with the help of
American involvement and it's depressing
for us right that's the reality but it's
the reality that we have to contend with
I don't know that there's much more to
say I get why they don't want Trump
there he'll add nothing and if anything
he'll take away